Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
On m'a dit que dans les TEDx,
il fallait pas dire bonjour.
Bonjour !
Moi, j’aime bien
faire un peu le fou d’entrée de jeu.
J’ai une question pour vous.
Répondez-y dans votre tête.
Combien vous noteriez votre vie
en ce moment sur une échelle de 1 à 10 ?
Là, maintenant, tout de suite,
sans réfléchir, à l’instinct.
J'adore cette question.
Elle nous oblige à être honnête
avec nous-mêmes
et à regarder les choses en face.
Maintenant, si vous le voulez bien,
je vais vous demander
de sortir votre téléphone.
Ça, ça va, c’est pas trop difficile.
Je vous en prie, allez-y !
D'ouvrir une conversation avec la personne
dont vous êtes le plus proche.
Et de lui envoyer cette note,
sans rien dire.
Et si vous n’avez pas de réseau,
envoyez-lui, ça partira après.
Pour la suite de l’expérience,
je vais, et vous allez voir,
c’est assez dingue,
je vais maintenant vous demander
de mettre votre téléphone en mode avion.
J’avoue, c’est juste pour être sûr que
vous restiez attentifs pendant la suite.
Bon, on va pas se mentir,
on vit une époque étrange.
C’est vrai, quand on pense au futur,
tout a l’air absolument merdique.
Il y a 50 ans, quand vous demandiez
à n’importe qui
ce qu’il imaginait
pour les années 2000, 2020,
tout le monde vous regardait
avec des étoiles dans les yeux
en vous parlant de voitures volantes,
d’énergies infinies,
de gratte-ciels tellement hauts
qu’on en verrait plus le sol.
Nous, quand on nous demande
ce qu’on imagine pour le futur,
c’est quand même un truc pas ouf,
à mi-chemin entre Walking Dead et une
espèce de grand barbecue climatique géant
dans lequel les humains
jouent le rôle de l’allume-feu.
Nous, notre grand projet collectif
de société, c’est survivre.
Vous le sentez qu’on s’est fait niquer,
là, un peu ou pas ?
Je m’appelle Artur
et j’ai un parcours bizarre.
J’ai grandi dans un petit village
de 200 habitants,
dans les montagnes, à côté du Jura.
Le genre d’endroit où, en gros,
soit tu fais du ski, soit tu meurs.
J’ai choisi d’aller en fac de sport
parce que je savais pas
ce que je voulais faire de ma vie
et que, comme ça, au moins, je pourrais
faire du sport en attendant de le savoir.
Il se trouve que, pendant ses études,
j’ai lancé un média
qui permettait aux gens
de raconter leurs pires anecdotes
sexuelles de manière anonyme.
Vous auriez dû voir la gueule de ma mère.
Contre toute attente, mais vraiment toute,
ce média a énormément grandi.
À tel point que j’en ai lancé d’autres.
Sur d’autres thématiques, je vous rassure.
C’est comme ça que j’ai créé
ma première boîte dans le digital,
que j’ai fini par revendre
à un groupe de dating
et que je me suis retrouvé dans une vie
entrepreneuriale complètement effrénée,
sans trop comprendre ce qui m’arrivait.
Alors des fois, ça a plutôt bien marché et
des fois, ça a un peu moins bien marché.
Comme la fois où j’ai claqué
toute la trésorerie de ma boîte
sur un coup de tête,
en oubliant qu’il me restait
120 000 euros de TVA à payer.
Les huissiers étaient
devant chez moi tous les jours.
J’ai cru qu’ils allaient
ouvrir un camping.
Mais bon, j'ai fait une fac
de sport, je me rappelle.
Bref, pendant toutes ces aventures,
j’ai eu l’occasion de me poser
beaucoup de questions
sur le fonctionnement de notre système,
que je voyais bien de l’intérieur
et sur son impact sur nous
et sur notre monde.
Et un des gros déclencheurs
de ces questionnements,
c’était la neige,
enfin plutôt l’absence de neige.
Chaque hiver, je voyais cette neige,
pourtant si abondante dans ma jeunesse,
disparaître complètement
de mes montagnes natales.
Ça peut paraître anodin, mais moi,
ça m’a vraiment fait quelque chose
parce que la plupart des stations
dans lesquelles j’ai appris le ski
et dans lesquelles j’ai beaucoup
de mes souvenirs d’enfance
ont juste complètement fermé
du jour au lendemain.
Du coup, je me suis intéressé au sujet.
Est-ce que vous savez
qu’il y a 20 000 ans,
il faisait en moyenne
5 degrés de moins sur Terre ?
À cette époque, la moitié de l’Europe
était recouverte d’un glacier
de 3 kilomètres d’épaisseur.
Genre dix fois la tour Eiffel en glace.
Le niveau des océans était
130 mètres plus bas.
Et le Sahara, il y a encore 6 000 ans,
c’était une forêt tropicale qui abritait
le plus grand lac du monde.
Ce que je veux vous dire là,
c’est qu’une variation en moyenne
de quelques degrés seulement,
ça te fout un bordel monstrueux.
Je pense qu’il ne vous aura pas échappé
qu’en ce moment,
on est en train de réchauffer
la température moyenne de la planète
comme jamais
dans l’histoire de l’humanité.
Les scénarios qu’on est en train de suivre
nous emmènent quelque part
entre +4 et +7 degrés
d’ici la fin du siècle.
Et ça, en gros, ça a le pouvoir
de mettre fin à la civilisation humaine.
Et c'est quand même pas très agréable.
Du coup, je me suis intéressé
aux limites de notre système
jusqu’à en faire carrément
le projet de ma vie.
Et très rapidement, je suis arrivé
à une conclusion simple.
Notre système a atteint son seuil
de contre productivité.
C’est vrai, tous les jours,
on attend les mauvaises nouvelles
comme si c’était normal.
Le climat, les pandémies,
la crise économique,
le mec qui dit chocolatine... et forcément
dans un système à bout de souffle,
on n’en a plus beaucoup non plus.
Un système qui rend littéralement
le monde invivable,
je pense qu’on peut dire
qu’il est devenu contre productif.
un système qui casse tous les liens,
les liens avec les autres,
les liens avec la nature,
les liens avec nous-mêmes,
je pense qu’on peut dire
qu’il est devenu contre productif.
Un système qui fait de nous
de simples agents économiques,
je ne sais pas pour vous,
mais pour moi, clairement
il est devenu contre productif.
L’humanité a mieux à apporter au monde
que d’être homo economicus,
ascendant homo oublie-pas-la-TVA-us,.
dont l’intelligence prodigieuse
l’a finalement conduit
à travailler en permanence pour un job
dont il ne voit pas l’intérêt
afin de s’acheter des trucs
dont il n’est pas sûr d’avoir besoin
entre deux burn-outs.
On mérite mieux que ça.
Franchement, on mérite
beaucoup mieux que ça.
Et cette période, c'est la parfaite
opportunité pour le prouver.
Parce que vous savez quoi ?
J'ai une très bonne nouvelle pour vous.
Quand on est au pied du mur, on ne peut
que changer radicalement de direction.
Sauf à la limite, si on est maçon,
je suis d’accord.
Depuis que je m’implique dans la lutte
contre le dérèglement climatique,
je côtoie des gens qui portent
des initiatives extraordinaires
et je me rends compte qu’un changement
de direction massif et hyper excitant
a déjà très largement commencé
pour mettre à jour ce système.
Partout, on remet en question
ce qui est censé être la norme.
En fait, on est en train de passer
du Moyen Âge à la Renaissance.
C’est juste qu’on ne voit pas
encore chaque jour.
Chaque jour, on me présente une nouvelle
personne
qui a quitté un job
hyper rémunérateur et confortable
juste pour se réaliser
et faire un truc utile.
C’est tellement violent
que plein de grands groupes
n’arrivent plus à recruter.
Au quotidien,
j’ai la chance de côtoyer
des milliers de personnes,
littéralement des milliers,
de tous les horizons,
qui investissent leur argent
pour financer et faire émerger
de nouveaux modèles
sans attendre
de retour sur investissement.
La pression est tellement forte
que tous les secteurs du monde
sont en train de se réinventer.
On dirait les débuts d’Internet,
mais en mille fois plus gros.
Et les vieux acteurs qui ne veulent
pas changer, il y en a toujours,
sont crispés, mais alors crispés !
Je vous jure, on dirait l’épreuve
des poteaux dans Koh-Lanta.
Alors oui, on nous parle de la fin
du monde à peu près tous les trois jours,
quand on allume la télé, on a l’impression
qu’on a poussé les portes de l’enfer.
Mais l'humanité fait des erreurs
en avançant et c'est normal.
Les erreurs, c’est un des meilleurs
leviers dont on dispose
pour retrouver
de l’énergie collectivemente
et faire changer un modèle
quand il ne nous convient plus.
Et c'est précisément ce qui
est en train de se passer.
La révolution du sens est en marche
et elle a besoin de nourrir ses rang
à force d’action et d’optimisme.
Elle a besoin de nous toutes et tous
pour devenir littéralement inarrêtable,
maintenant.
Et chaque individu de plus
va faire la différence.
C’est la citation de Margaret Mead
que vous avez probablement déjà lue
à peu près 300 000 fois
sur les réseaux sociaux,
mais je vais quand même vous la dire.
Ne doutez jamais qu'un petit nombre
d'individus puisse changer le monde.
En réalité, c’est toujours ainsi
que le monde a changé.
Tout à l’heure, je vous ai demandé
de faire un truc chelou,
je vous ai demandé de noter
votre vie sur une échelle de 1 à 10.
Maintenant, j’aimerais vous donner un hack
pour augmenter drastiquement
cette note dans les prochains mois.
Et vous allez voir,
ça marche à tous les coups.
À partir de maintenant, s’il vous plaît,
ne laissez plus jamais personne
vous voler l’espoir.
Refusez cette espèce de fatalisme ambiant
qui nous emmène nulle part,
c’est de la merde !
La meilleure des façons de perdre,
c’est de considérer qu’on a déjà perdu.
Mais on n'a pas perdu.
Il n'est pas trop tard et nous avons
toujours l'incroyable pouvoir de décider
du monde dans lequel on veut vivre.
Ce n’est pas moi qui le dis.
C’est des dizaines de scientifiques
partout dans le monde
qui ont décidé de consacrer
leur vie à ces questions.
Je vous invite donc officiellement
à rejoindre le côté optimiste de la force.
Et ça ne veut pas dire être naïf
ou déconnecté de la réalité.
Ça ne veut pas dire qu’on fait comme
si il n’y avait pas de problème, non !
Ça veut juste dire
qu’à partir de maintenant,
on refuse tout ce qui n’a pas de sens
et qui nique notre avenir,
et on encourage tout ce qui en a.
Tout le temps, dans tout
ce qu’on fait au quotidien.
Même si on n’est pas irréprochable,
personne ne peut être irréprochable
dans un monde qui n’a lui-même
pas fait sa mutation.
On n’a plus le temps pour la légitimité,
il faut qu’on avance
et on pourra
le faire que tous ensemble.
C'est à nous de choisir notre futur
et il est grand temps de le faire.
C’est à nous de choisir notre futur,
et il peut être beau
parce que la fin du monde,
franchement, c’est chiant !
Merci.